Senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
was one of President Trump's biggest
critics and now he might be the Trump
whisperer in fact he voted for ever
McMullen we understand when all was said
and done but at the end of two 17 he's
become an unexpected ally and confidant
to President Trump by almost all
accounts so what does senator Graham
think about the Trump administration's
first-year Robert Moores ongoing probe
and the prospects for 2018 and why
January might be as big as December for
for Congress senator welcome thanks for
joining us I think that's pretty good
lead-in thanks so much thank you I mean
it's been just fascinating to see the
way you guys want at it and now you have
this very honest upfront mutual
relationship and respect for each other
in my humble opinion and Senator why do
you believe that something will get done
with immigration what could you tell the
people right now that might give them a
sense of optimism heading into the new
year well I think the president outlined
what the deal will look like about 80%
of the American people want these DREAM
Act kids to have a a good life they
don't want to kick them out of the
country because they've got no place
else to go they've been here since
they're pretty small kids 80 percent of
the people would like to see the border
secured with a wall component you need a
wall on the border not the entire border
border security with a wall makes sense
most Americans would like to get away
from chain migration so there's a deal
to be had and the only reason we won't
get a deal is because people are so
stubborn they can't get the yes I think
we'll get to yes well I tell you what I
read senator Schumer's Twitter feed and
he says listen daca is with the budget
and we're gonna pass the budget with
daca nothing to do with border security
and and if we and we're not going to
link it to the wall so therefore
government doesn't get funded you think
that's not reality there's something
going on behind the scenes that makes
you feel as though we're past that
rhetoric what is I'm I'm deeply involved
with working with Democrats I'm one of
the authors of the dream that was
Senator Durbin I think most Americans
believe that not only should these kids
have a you know a a second chance on
life here that we do need to secure a
border so this idea that we're only
going to do the DREAM Act and nothing
else is just all political theater we
have to do more than the DREAM Act and
we will but you wanted you want to trust
a migration you want to
address the lottery system you want to
get the border security done and you
want to get the dream thing done so do
you believe they're all gonna be linked
because Mitch McConnell says if you guys
work it out and you're white working in
a bipartisan way right now behind the
scenes and you put it to him he's gonna
put it to a vote and what's significant
is he's going to say I'll pass it even
if majority Republicans don't go for it
that's what he means when he says I'll
put it to a vote right yeah I think it'd
be pretty hard to go back home and say
that you voted against a secure border
with a wall component the president's
not saying of twenty-two hundred mile
walk but there places we need a wall and
he's going to get his wall and border
security because that's what he ran on
Democrats had been working with
Republicans like myself for a decade now
try to find a way to fix the DREAM Act
their problem that needs to be done most
people don't like chain migration the
lottery system is just the dumbest way
in the world to give out visas so
everything comes together to get this
package all right and you believe
January I hope so sooner rather than
later here's what I'd like to be able to
do I'd like the President to address the
nation in the State of the Union and say
I've increased defense spending because
it had to be increased our military
suffered too long and I fixed it we got
a border secured with a wall where it
makes sense the DREAM Act kids have a
better life and we're moving away from a
stupid lottery system to a merit-based
immigration system I like for the
president be able to say that in January
I think that's possible only if dick
Durbin says the same thing to be honest
even if you might not agree with them if
he can't if he if he's not nodding
somewhere in Illinois we're not gonna
get anywhere and we've been down that
road before senator I want to move to a
one-on-one of the president Trump's 101
tweets in the last couple of days and
one of them said in his interview with
the New York Times which he gave that
any aides around an impromptu fashion at
the grill at his grill in in Florida he
said I think Robert Muller will do a
fair job an honest job he's confident
he'll do a good job on this
investigation from a legal perspective
and with your legal background I know
that makes you happy because to
criticize Robert Mahler's does not is
not a
thing to do necessarily legally but do
you believe that he's pursuing this
thing in an honest fashion from what you
know not what you hope but what you know
yeah yeah I believe he is I believe he's
the right guy to have been chosen he's
going to give a reanalysis of what
happened in a fair hint in a fair-minded
way but he's not looking at the dossier
that's not part of his Charter and I've
spent some time in the last couple of
days after a lot of fighting with the
Department of Justice to get the
background on the dossier and here's
what I can tell your viewers I'm very
disturbed about what the Department of
Justice did with his this dossier and we
need a special counsel to look into that
because that's not in Muller's charter
and what I saw and what what I've
gathered in the last couple of days
bothers me a lot and I'd like somebody
outside DOJ to look into how this
dossier was handled and what they did
with it way to say so you found out
something you did not know and you were
already disturbed by it and is about the
what's in the in the contents of it or
how it was used for this investigation
and unmasking possible Trump officials
I've been a lawyer most of my life a
prosecutor and a defense attorney and
the one thing I can say every prosecutor
has a duty to the court to disclose
things that are irrelevant to the
request so anytime but document is used
to go to court for legal reasons I think
the Department of Justice owes it to to
the court to be up and up about exactly
what this document is about who paid for
it who's involved what their motives
might be and I can just say this after
having looked at the history of the
dossier and how it was used by the
Department of Justice I'm really very
concerned and this cannot be the new
normal Wow and senator I'm over over
time but name the company in South
Carolina that's responding to the tax
reform and how new pron is a
pharmaceutical company they gave a 5% in
wage increase to all their employees
specifically because of the tax cut the
average person makes seventy thousand
dollars a year five percent pay raise is
real money when you look at
tax cut plus the pay raise plus the
increase in the 401k plan this has been
a very good presidency for people who
are working after President Trump's tax
cut is going to help work in people his
policies have generated a lot of
economic growth in 401k plans and
employers are sharing the the profits of
the tax cut with their employees which
makes me very happy
senator thanks so much in the Lindsey
Graham have a great new year I'll talk
to you early and often in 2018 thank you